[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIGHTMAN: Welcome.
It's very nice to see
so many people here,
which I think is a tribute
to our speaker tonight.
I'm Alan Lightman.
And I'm head of MIT's Program in
Writing and Humanistic Studies,
which is part of the School of
Humanities and Social Sciences.
For many years now,
our program has
been sponsoring a writers series
in which we invite leading
thinkers and writers
to the MIT campus
to talk and to read
from their works.
These events are all free
and open to the public.
Tonight we are
honored to have Susan
Sontag as the first speaker
in this year's writer series.
And I want to thank everyone
who has been involved
with planning tonight's events.
I'm already dry.
[LAUGHTER]
Susan Sontag is a
national treasure.
Her intellectual and literary
talents span every genre.
Her essays on American
culture, for example,
are characterized by insight and
beautiful writing and a deeply
philosophical perspective.
Ms. Sontag's books include
the novels, The Benefactor,
Death Kit, and her
recent, The Volcano Lover.
Her essays have been
collected in such books
as Against
Interpretation, Styles
of Radical Will, On Photography,
and Under the Sign of Saturn.
And she has two book length
essays, Illness as Metaphor,
and AIDS and Its Metaphors.
She has written and directed
four feature length films.
And her new play Alice in Bed
has been produced in Germany
and receive its American
premiere next fall.
She has won numerous awards.
And I'll just mention a few.
Her book, On Photography,
won the National Book Critics
Circle Award.
From 1987 to 1989,
she was president
of the American
Center of PEN, which
is the international
writers organization.
And in 1990, she was awarded
a very prestigious MacArthur
Fellowship.
As many of you know, she
went to Sarajevo in July
to stage a production
of Waiting for Godot.
That production has been
met with much acclaim.
She wrote a beautiful
article describing it
in a recent issue of the
New York Review of Books.
And she has been named an
honorary citizen of Sarajevo.
We are honored to have Susan
Sontag with us tonight.
In a few minutes, we
are going to be joined
by another honored guest.
And for security reasons,
I ask that none of you
leave the room once the
program is underway.
The event should last
until about 7:30.
I'm sorry-- well, you
can see that I'm very
calm about this whole thing.
The event should last
until about 9:30.
And if any of you think that
you cannot remain in your seats
until 9:30, then I'm going to
give you the chance to leave
the room right now.
So I'll wait.
I'll wait just a minute.
I want to give you
a chance to leave.
I would recommend staying.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, and I'm very, very happy to
introduce to you Susan Sontag.
[APPLAUSE]
SONTAG: I want to begin this
evening by doing two things.
First of all, I want to
speak about a friend of mine,
the great English writer--
or perhaps I should
say British writer--
Salman Rushdie, who has
been under sentence of death
for almost five years.
As many of you know,
on February 14, 1989
a fatwa or death
sentence was issued
by the Ayatollah
Khomeini of Iran,
which calls on Muslims
everywhere to kill Salman
Rushdie and also to kill his
publishers, his translators,
the booksellers, his
agents, presumably,
by extension, the people
who buy and read his book.
There is a bounty offered of
more than two million dollars
for the assassins.
And there are
assassins everywhere
seeking Salman Rushdie,
hoping to collect this bounty.
Why was Salman Rushdie
sentenced to death?
Why was a British citizen,
an English citizen
sentenced to death
by a religious leader
in a foreign country?
Because he wrote a novel.
He wrote a novel.
It wasn't even his first novel.
It's a great novel.
But he'd written some other
great novels before it, notably
Midnight's Children.
And between Midnight's Children
and the novel for which he
was sentenced to death,
a novel called Shame,
Salman Rushdie was already a
well-known and very admired
writer.
He is one of the great
writers of our time.
Now he is famous and exemplary
for reasons that could hardly
be imagined a few years ago.
And we've all had
a great education
thinking about the
predicament of Salman Rushdie.
This has been going on, as I
say, for almost five years.
On February 14, 1994,
it will be five years
that Salman Rushdie has lived
in hiding, under constant guard.
There are assassin teams
everywhere looking for him.
He has had many narrow escapes.
He is obliged to move
from house to house.
This is the life he has
been living for five years.
Assassins have sought,
and in a number
of cases, reached other
people his Japanese translator
was murdered in July, 1991.
And his Italian translator,
on practically the same day--
it was a coordinated
assassination attempt--
was severely wounded
and very only luckily
and barely escaped
with his life.
And in October, just
a few weeks ago,
his Norwegian publisher,
an assassination attempt,
also nearly successful, was
made on his Norwegian publisher.
It's worth mentioning
that none of the people,
of course, who are seeking
Salman Rushdie's life
to collect this bounty
have read this book,
have even seen a
copy of this book.
And it's certainly
worth underscoring
that they do not represent
the great traditions of Islam.
Just recently in
Paris, and I'm sure it
will be shortly translated
into English, 100 prominent--
indeed some of them
very great intellectuals
and writers from
the Islamic world--
declared their solidarity
with Salman Rushdie.
And these include, for instance,
the great Egyptian novelist
Mahfouz who won the Nobel
Prize several years ago.
The Rushdie case raises
the most urgent issues,
issues that concern all of us.
The book, The
Satanic Verses, which
has been read by none of the
people who attack it and want
to murder Salman
Rushdie for writing it,
the book and the reactions
to it are very complex
and richly emblematic.
But the man, the
writer, the human being,
and his predicament,
his constant danger
is not emblematic at all.
It's absolutely real.
Salman Rushdie is particularly
exemplary in the way
he has assumed his destiny.
Because in these very,
very painful and dangerous
and terrifying five years,
he's gone on being a writer.
He's produced another novel.
He is working on--
I'm sure I'm omitting something.
He's been so active in the
midst of all this horror.
He is writing still
another novel.
He has published a number
of extraordinary essays
and given speeches defending
the basic human right
to liberty of expression.
He reviews books regularly.
And some of you may have seen
his reviews in the New York
Times and elsewhere.
He even gives blurbs to
writers, far too many, I think.
But he is--
I can understand that he wants
to go on participating fully
in the literary world.
What Salman Rushdie stands for
is the right to secularism,
pluralism, to freedom of
expression, to tolerance,
values that I hope we are all
united in supporting, values, I
might add, for which the
new nation-state of Bosnia
is also being murdered
for standing up
for values of pluralism and
secularism and tolerance.
Salman Rushdie is only the
most visible individual victim
of a worldwide struggle
against tolerance,
against anti-tribal
enlightened spirit of freedom.
And he would be the
first to say that.
He would be the first
to say my case stands
for many other cases as well.
I think that his cause
honoring his rights
and his exemplary
conduct since the fatwa
should be our cause as, indeed,
while he lives minute by minute
under constant threat of
death, which has not abated,
he never forgets that
he is fighting not just
to stay alive, but to hold back
the immense force of terror,
those who would silence
honesty and strangle dialogue.
Salman Rushdie is still alive.
But his predicament,
the sentence
of terror and intimidation,
that has been carried out.
And the worst kind of
censorship is self-censorship.
This case is the
great test of where
we stand on the issue of
freedom and solidarity
and the future of
our own culture.
That's the first thing I wanted
to do to open this evening.
And the second thing,
not surprisingly,
is I wanted to introduce
Salman Rushdie.
[APPLAUSE]
Good evening.
My name is Mark Wrighton.
I'm the provost of MIT.
And first, I want to
thank Susan Sontag
for joining us this evening, for
introducing our special guest,
and for making this
evening possible.
Would you join me
in thanking her?
[APPLAUSE]
Unfortunately,
President Vest could not
be with us this evening,
owing to a prior commitment
outside Cambridge.
But I am pleased to
present on his behalf
and on behalf of the MIT
community, a citation
and an award to Mr. Rushdie.
I will present the letter
that President Vest
has written to Mr. Rushdie.
And in it he says,
"In recognition
of your outstanding
contributions
to world literature
and in recognition
of the independence of
thought and expression
that you have come to represent,
the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology proudly appoints
you honorary visiting professor
of the humanities."
[APPLAUSE]
It's a real privilege for me to
be on this stage this evening.
So many people have worked
hard to make it possible,
especially Alan Lightman, the
head of our Program in Writing
and Humanistic Studies,
and Anita Desai, a person
we've been very fortunate
to attract to our faculty.
This is a special
evening, of course.
We're very privileged to host
this distinguished speaker.
We honor him.
And we celebrate our
freedom of expression.
[APPLAUSE]
RUSHDIE: Thank you.
Well I have to--
I have a lot of people
to thank, first of all.
Good evening all of you.
It's nice to be here.
Although I was going to
apologize for the kind of cloak
and dagger aspect of this.
But actually Susan Sontag and
I have been looking forward
to this surprise for so long,
it's actually quite nice
to pull it off .
And first of all,
I want to thank her
for being what she
described as my beard.
It means I now have two.
I also, of course,
would like to thank
MIT for this incredible honor,
which is, I have to say,
the first academic honor
I've ever received.
So it's nice to
start at the top.
I was saying just before we
all came on here that I was--
see, the plan for me is I was
supposed to be a scientist.
When I was 16,
there's no question
that my best subjects
were math and physics.
And everybody from
my parents downwards
assumed that that's
what I would do.
But at some point, for reasons
of stubbornness and perversity,
I took a dramatic left turn and
did history, French, and Latin
instead.
And I've always
regretted the loss
of that scientific dimension.
It's nice to kind
of get it back free.
And I really do hope that this
isn't just a symbolic moment,
but that it can be the beginning
of a long term relationship
with this great institution.
I think many of us,
writers of my generation,
have felt that in many ways
the cutting edge of the new
is now to be found
in the sciences,
not in philosophy,
not in the arts,
and that actually
we have a great deal
to absorb and learn from.
And so I look forward
to being able to do that
in the company of all of you
and of the remarkable talents
and minds present at MIT.
And I think for that
reason, the fact
that this is such a great
institution dedicated
to the search for the new and
to the openness of thought
that that search
requires, I think
it's very appropriate and very,
a very great privilege for me
to receive this honor from, of
all places, this institution.
And I thank them
once again for that.
Susan Sontag spoke so eloquently
about the issues surrounding
the so-called Rushdie
case that there is not
very much I want to
add except to endorse
all the arguments she made.
I just wanted to say
one thing that it's
been going on for five years
and that's a very long time.
It's also long
enough to understand
exactly what is going on.
For a long time, I
think, when this began,
the fact that the
language of censorship,
of political oppression
and persecution
was wrapped in a kind
of cloak of religion
meant that people did
not see it plainly.
And that's natural, in
a way, because that's
a language which people respect,
that if that language is used
to cloak evil, it
takes some time
for the evil inside the cloak
to make its presence felt.
I think it's now perfectly
clear the nature of, the nature
of the evil that lies
behind such threats
as the one aimed against
the Satanic Verses.
And I think it's very important
what Susan pointed out,
that this is not just a
threat against one individual.
It's a threat against,
if you put together
all the people involved in
the production of a book,
literally thousands of
people in many countries.
And in fact, you could say
that I am the best protected
person of all those people.
The shooting of William
Nygaard, my very courageous
Norwegian publisher makes
me feel determined or even
more determined to try
and make sure that this
is the last such atrocity.
And for that, I'm
afraid, I need your help.
Because the only weapon that
I have is public opinion.
In the end, the governments
of the democratic world
will act in this
matter only if they
believe it's a matter
of sufficient interest
to their own
citizens and voters.
They won't do it for me.
They might do it for you.
It's therefore
extremely important
that the citizens of
democratic countries
understand and make
plain that the case
of the murder of a
writer or a publisher
or a bookseller or a translator
is an insult to their freedom.
It's not just an act
against the individual.
The attempt to suppress the
book is the attempt not just
to suppress the right
of a writer to writer
or a publisher to publish or
a translator to translate,
it's also the attempt to
suppress the right of a reader
to read and of out of
all of us to choose
that which we choose to read.
So I ask you to continue to put
pressure on your own government
in order to make sure that
it as fully as possible
joins the international
campaign against this threat.
For one final reason,
which is that I've
sat down for five years,
that any form of terrorism
which seems to succeed
will be repeated.
Here is the invention,
you might say,
of a new form of terrorism,
a successor to two airplane
hijacks and the taking
of hostages here.
We have a kind of
terrorism at a distance,
a kind of remote control
terrorism, which simply
points a finger across
the world and asks
for the elimination
of certain individuals
and offers financial rewards--
and not just financial
rewards, but the promise,
from a dubious
promise of paradise.
If this form of terrorism
seems to be working,
it will be repeated.
And the sad fact is that it
is already being repeated.
Within the last
few months, we've
seen the assassination of the
writer Tahar Djaout of Algeria,
the assassination of
the secularists thinker,
Farag Foda in Egypt, the
offer of six figure sums
in dollars for the
assassination of the writer Aziz
Nesin in Turkey, and
most recently, the offer
of a large sum of money by
Islamic fanatics in Bangladesh
for the murder of the young
feminist novelist, Taslima
Nasrin whose crime,
whose so-called blasphemy
was that she wrote a novel
deploring the revenge
killings in Bangladesh of
Hindus by Islamic fanatics
after the destruction of the
Muslim-- the mosque in Ayodhya
in India.
For this, she is to
be sentenced to death.
Here is evidence, if
ever it was needed,
that this is a technique which
is beginning to look popular.
And the reason that's the
reason it's becoming popular
is that it seems to have worked.
It's therefore
important to demonstrate
that it didn't work.
And I think in the end, the only
way you can show a terrorist
and what he is doing
doesn't work, is to say,
"I'm not scared of you."
The purpose of terrorism
is to terrorize.
The only defense
against terrorism
is to refuse to be terrorized.
We have to, therefore,
avoid our own fear.
Because that can do the
terrorists' work for them.
And so it seemed to me
that instead of banging on
for one evening, just this
evening, instead of talking
about the government of Iran,
a subject in which I have
incredibly little interest,
and instead of accepting
their decision to turn me into
some kind of demonized figure,
I would say I'm not that kind of
writer, I'm this kind of writer
and read to you.
And I thought I would read
not from The Satanic Verses,
just for a change give
The Satanic Verses a rest,
thought I'd read from an
earlier novel of mine,
Midnight's Children, a novel
which begins like this.
"I was born in the city of
Bombay, once upon a time.
No, that won't do.
There's no getting
away from the date.
I was born in Doctor
Narlikar's Nursing Home
on August 15, 1947.
And the time, the
time matters too.
Well, then at night.
No, it's important to be more--
on the stroke of midnight,
as a matter of fact.
Clock-hands joined palms and
respectful greeting as I came.
Oh, spell it out, spell it out.
At the precise instant
of India's arrival
at independence, I tumbled
forth into the world.
There were gasps.
And, outside the window,
fireworks and crowds.
A few seconds later, my
father broke his big toe.
But his accident
was a mere trifle
when set beside what
had befallen me.
Because thanks to the occult
tyrannies of those blindly
saluting clocks, I had been
mysteriously handcuffed
to history.
My destiny is indissolubly
chained to those of my country.
For the next three decades,
there was to be no escape.
Soothsayers had prophesied me.
Newspapers celebrated
my arrival.
Politicos ratified
my authenticity.
I was left entirely without
a say in the matter.
I, Saleem Sinai, later variously
called Snotnose, Stainface,
Baldy, Sniffer, Buddha,
and even Piece-of-the-Moon,
had become heavily embroiled
in fate, at the best of times,
a dangerous sort of involvement.
And I couldn't even wipe
my own nose at the time."
Well, that's how it begins.
I'm just going to read
you a couple of passages
from later in the book.
They both happen about 10
years after that birth.
Saleem, by this
stage, what we know
about him is that he's not
really his parents' child
because he'd been
changed, changed in the--
swapped in the
hospital by accident.
He's also, by this
stage, acquired
a kind of incipient
gift of telepathy,
which features somewhat
in what follows.
His mother, or the
woman who he thinks
is his mother has
been previously
married, but separated from her
previous husband, is remarried.
He has recently, owing to
his telepathic abilities,
also his habit of eavesdropping
on telephone calls,
discovered that she has begun
to have mysterious telephone
conversations with
a strange man.
So he decides to follow her
on one of these assignations
by hiding in the
trunk of her car.
"Once upon a time,
there was a mother,
who in order to become a mother,
had agreed to change her name,
who set herself
the task of falling
in love with her
husband bit-by-bit,
but who could never manage
to love one part, the part,
curiously enough, which made
possible her motherhood, whose
feet were hobbled by verrucas
and whose shoulders were
stooped beneath the accumulating
guilts of the world, whose
husband's unlovable
organ failed to recover
from the effects of a freeze,
and who, like her husband,
finally succumbed to the
mysteries of telephones,
spending long minutes
listening to the words
of wrong-number
telephone callers.
Shortly after my 10th
birthday, Amina Sinai
resumed her recent practice
of leaving suddenly and always
immediately after a wrong
number on urgent shopping trips.
But now, hidden in
the boot of the Rover,
there traveled
with her a stowaway
who lay hidden and protected
by stolen cushions,
clutching a thin strip of
pink plastic in his hand.
O, the suffering one undergoes
in the name of righteousness!
The bruising and the bumps!
The breathing in of rubbery
boot-air through jolted teeth!
And constantly, the
fear of discovery.
'Suppose she really
does go shopping?
Will the boot suddenly fly open?
Will live chickens be flung
in, feet tied together,
wings clipped, fluttery pecky
birds invading my hidey-hole?
Will she see me?
My god, I'll have to
be quiet for a week.'
My knees drawn in
beneath my chin,
which was protected against
bumps by an old faded cushion.
I voyaged into the
unknown in the vehicle
of maternal perfidy.
My mother was a cautious driver.
She went slowly and
turned corners with care.
But afterwards, I was
bruised black and blue
and my Mary Pereira
berated me soundly
for getting into fights.
'Arré God, what a thing.
It's a wonder they didn't
smash you to pieces completely.
My God, what will you grow up
into you, you bad black man,
you haddi-phaelwan, you
skin-and-bone wrestler!'
To take my mind off
the jolting darkness,
I entered, with extreme caution,
that part of my mother's
mind which was in charge
of driving operations,
and as a result was able
to follow her route.
And also to discern in my
mother's habitually tidy mind,
an alarming degree of disorder.
I was already
beginning in those days
to classify people by their
degree of internal tidiness
and to discover that I preferred
the messier type, whose
thoughts spilling
constantly into one another
so that anticipatory
images of food
interfered with the serious
business of earning a living
and sexual fantasies
were superimposed
upon their political
musings, bore a closer
relationship to my own pell-mell
tumble of a brain in which
everything ran into
everything else
and the white dot
of consciousness
jumped about like a wild flea
from one thing to the next.
Amina Sinai, whose
assiduous ordering instincts
had provided her with a brain
of almost abnormal neatness,
was a curious recruit to
the ranks of confusion.
We headed north, past Breach
Candy Hospital Mahalaxmi
Temple, north along
Hornby Vellard,
past Vallabhbhai Stadium
and Haji Ali's island tomb,
north of what had once
been the island of Bombay.
We were heading towards the
anonymous mass of tenements
and fishing villages and
textile plants and film studios
that the city became in these
northern zones, an area which
was, in those days,
utterly unknown to me.
I rapidly became
disoriented and was then
obliged to admit to
myself that I was lost.
At last, down an
unprepossessing side street
full of drainpipe-sleepers
and bicycle repair
shops and tattered men
and boys, we stopped.
Clusters of children assailed
my mother as she descended.
And she, who could
never shoo away a fly,
handed out small coins, thus
enlarging the crowd enormously.
Eventually, she
struggled away from them
and headed down the street.
There was a boy, pleading,
'Gib the car poliss, Begum?
Number one A-class
poliss, Begum?
I watch car till you come.
Begum?
I very fine watchman.
Ask anyone.'
In some panic, I listened
in for her reply.
How could I get out of this boot
under the eyes of a guardian
urchin?
There was the
embarrassment of it.
And besides, my emergence
would have created
a sensation in the street.
My mother said no.
She was disappearing
down the street.
The would-be polisher and
watchman gave up eventually.
There was a moment
when all eyes turned
to watch the passing
of a second car,
just in case it too stopped to
disgorge a lady who gave away
coins as if they were nuts.
And in that instant--
I had been looking through
several pairs of eyes
to help me choose my moment--
I performed my trick
with the pink plastic
and was out in the street beside
the closed car boot in a flash.
Setting my lips
grimly and ignoring
all outstretched palms, I
set off in the direction
of my mother had taken,
a pocket sized sleuth
with the nose of a bloodhound--"
he has a very big nose--
"and a loud drum pounding in
the place where my heart should
have been and arrived a few
minutes later at the Pioneer
Café.
Dirty glass in the window,
dirty glasses on the tables,
the Pioneer Café was not much
when compared to the Gaylords
and Kwalitys of the city's
more glamorous parts,
a real rutputty joint with
painted boards proclaiming
'Lovely Lassi' and 'Funtabulous
Falooda' and 'Bhel-Puribombay
Fashion,' with filmi playback
music blaring out from a cheap
radio by the cash-till a
long, narrow greeny room lit
by flickering neon, a forbidding
world in which broken-toothed
men sat at reccine-covered
tables with crumpled cards
and expressionless eyes.
But for all its
grimy decrepitude,
the Pioneer Café was a
repository of many dreams.
Early each morning, it would
be full of the best-looking
ne'er-do-wells in the city, all
the goondas and taxi-drivers
and petty smugglers and
racecourse tipsters who had
once ago, once long ago arrived
in the city dreaming of film
stardom, of grotesquely vulgar
homes and black money payments.
Because every morning at six,
the major studios would send
minor functionaries to the
Pioneer Café to rope in extras
for the day's shooting.
For half an hour each
morning when DW Rama Studios
and Filmistan Talkies and RK
Films were taking their pick,
the Pioneer was the focus of all
the city's ambitions and hopes.
Then the studio scouts
left, accompanied
by the day's lucky ones.
And the Café emptied into its
habitual, neon-lit torpor.
Around lunchtime, a different
set of dreams walked
into the Café to spend the
afternoon hunched over cards
and Lovely Lassi
and rough biris--
different men with
different hopes.
I didn't know it then,
but the afternoon Pioneer
was a notorious
Communist Party hangout.
It was afternoon.
I saw my mother enter
the Pioneer Café.
Not daring to follow her,
I stayed in the street
pressing my nose against
a spider-webbed corner
of the grubby window pane.
Ignoring the curious
glances I got--
because my whites, although
boot-stained were nevertheless
starched, my hair, although
rumpled, was well oiled,
my shoes, scuffed as they
were, were still the plimsolls
of a prosperous child--
I followed her
with my eyes as she
went hesitantly and
verruca-hobbled past rickety
tables and hard-eyed men.
I saw my mother sit down at a
shadowed table at the far end
of the narrow cavern.
And then I saw the man
who rose to greet her.
The skin on his
face hung in folds
which revealed that he
had once been overweight.
His teeth were
stained with paan.
He wore a clean white
kurta with Lucknow-work
around the buttonholes.
He had long hair,
poetically long,
hanging lankly over his ears.
But the top of his head
was bald and shiny.
Forbidden syllables
echoed in my ears.
Na.
Dir.
Nadir."
That's the name of
the first husband.
"I realized that I wished
desperately that I'd never
resolved to come.
Once upon a time, there
was an underground husband
who fled, leaving loving
messages of divorce, a poet
whose verses didn't even rhyme.
After a lost decade, he
emerged from goodness
knows where, his skin
hanging loose in memory
of his erstwhile plumpness.
And like his once
upon a time wife,
he had acquired a new name.
Nadir Khan was now Qasim
Khan, official candidate
of the official
Communist Party of India.
Lal Qasim, Qasim the Red.
Nothing is without meaning.
Not without reason
are blushes red.
My uncle said, 'Watch
out for the Communists!'
And my mother turned scarlet.
Politics and emotions
were united in her cheeks.
Through the dirty, square,
glossy cinema-screen
of the Pioneer Café's
window, I watched Amina Sinai
and the no-longer-Nadir
play out their love scene.
They performed with the
ineptitude of genuine amateurs.
On the table, a packet of
cigarettes, State Express 555.
Numbers too have significance.
420, the name given to frauds,
1,001, the number of night,
of magic, of
alternative realities,
a number beloved of
poets and detested
by politicians for whom
all alternative versions
of the world are threats,
and 555, which for years I
believed to be the most
sinister of numbers,
the cipher of the Devil, the
Great Beast, Shaitan himself!
But the true demonic
number is not 555, but 666.
Yet in my mind, a dark aura
hangs around the three fives
to this day.
But I am getting carried away.
Suffice to say that Nadir
Qasim's preferred brand was
the aforesaid State Express,
that the figure five was
repeated three
times on the packet,
and then the manufacturers
were WD and HO Wells.
Unable to look into
my mother's face,
I concentrated on
the cigarette packet,
cutting from too short of
lovers to this extreme close-up
of nicotine.
But now, hands into the frame.
First, the hands of Nadir Qasim,
their poetic softness somewhat
calloused these days, hands
flickering like candle flames,
creeping forward across
reccine, then jerking back.
Next, a woman's
hands, black as jet,
inching forward like
elegant spiders,
hands lifting up
off the table top,
hands hovering
above three fives,
beginning the
strangest of dances--
rising, falling,
circling one another,
weaving in and out between each
other, hands longing for touch,
hands outstretching,
tensing, quivering,
demanding to be, but always
at last jerking back.
Fingertips avoiding fingertips
because what I'm watching here
on my dirty glass cinema
screen is, after all,
an Indian movie, in
which physical contact
is forbidden lest it
corrupt the watching
flower of Indian youth.
And there are feet beneath
the table and faces above it,
feet advancing
towards feet, faces
tumbling softly towards
faces, but jerking away
all of a sudden in a
cruel censor's cut.
Two strangers, each
bearing a screen name which
is not the name of
their birth, act out
their half unwanted roles.
I left the movie before
the end to slip back
into the boot of the
unpolished, unwatched Rover,
wishing I hadn't gone to see
it, unable to resist wanting
to watch it all over again.
What I saw at the
very end, my mother's
hands raising a half empty glass
of Lovely Lassi, my mother's
lips pressing
gently, nostalgically
against the mottled
glass, my mother's hands
handing the glass
to her Nadir Qasim,
who also applied to the
opposite side of the glass
his own poetic mouth.
So it was that life imitated
bad art and my film director
sister--
my uncle, the film director's,
sister brought the eroticism
of the indirect kiss into
the green neon dinginess
of the Pioneer Café.
To sum up, in the high summer of
1957 at the peak of an election
campaign, Amina Sinai
blushed inexplicably
at a chance mention of the
Communist Party of India.
Her son followed her into
the north of the city
and spied on a pain-filled
scene of impotent love.
Questions-- did I ever,
after that time employ
the services of pink plastic?
Did I return to the cafe
of extras and Marxists?
Did I confront my mother
with the heinous nature
of her offense?
Because what mother has any
business to-- never mind about
what once-upon-a-time in
full view of her only son,
how could she?
How could she?
Answers-- I did not,
I did not, I did not."
Well that's-- a little later
something else not very
pleasant happens to him.
He's having a bad 10th year--
11th year, I beg his pardon,
he's already been 10.
"The first mutilation of
Saleem Sinai, which was rapidly
followed by the second,
took place one Wednesday
early in 1958, the Wednesday
of the much-anticipated social
under the auspices of the
Anglo-Scottish Education
Society.
That is to say, it
happened at school.
Saleem's assailant--
handsome, frenetic,
with a barbarian's
shaggy mustache.
I present the leaping,
hair-tearing figure
of Mr. Emil Zagallo who taught
us geography and gymnastics
and who, that morning,
unintentionally precipitated
the crisis of my life.
Zagallo claimed to be Peruvian
and was fond of calling us
jungle-Indians, bead lovers.
He hung a print of a stern,
sweaty soldier in a pointy tin
hat and metal pantaloons
above his blackboard
and had a way of stabbing a
finger at it in times of stress
and shouting, 'You
see him, you savages?
This man is civilization!
You show him respect.
He's got a sword!'
And he would swish his cane
through the stonewalled air.
We called him Pagal-Zagal,
crazy Zagallo.
Because for all his talk
of llamas and conquistadors
and the Pacific Ocean, we knew
with the absolute certainty
of rumor that he'd been
born in a Mazagaon tenement
and his Goanese mother
had been abandoned
by a decamped shipping agent.
So he was not only an Anglo,
but probably a bastard as well.
Knowing this, we understood
why Zagallo affected
his Latin accent and also
why he was always in a fury,
why he beat his fists
against the stone wall, walls
of the classroom.
But the knowledge didn't
stop us being afraid.
And this Wednesday morning,
we knew we were in for trouble
because Optional Cathedral
had been canceled.
The Wednesday
morning double period
was Zagallo's geography class.
But only idiots and boys
with bigoted parents
attended it because
it was also the time
when we could choose to troop
off to St. Thomas's Cathedral
in crocodile formation,
a long line of boys
of every conceivable religious
denomination escaping
from school into the
bosom of the Christians'
considerately optional god.
It drove Zagallo wild.
But he was helpless.
Today, however, there was
a dark glint in his eye
because Mr. Crusoe,
the headmaster
had announced at
morning assembly
that Cathedral was canceled.
In a bare, scraped
voice he sentenced
us, sentenced us to double
geography and Pagal-Zagal,
taking us all by
surprise because we
hadn't realized that
God was permitted
to exercise an option too.
Glumly, we trooped
into Zagallo's lair.
One of the poor
idiots whose parents
never allowed them
to go to Cathedral
whispered viciously into
my ear, 'You just wait.
He'll really get
you guys today.'
He really did.
Seated gloomily in class--
Glandy Keith Colaco,
Fat Perce Fishwala,
Jimmy Kapadia the
scholarship boy
whose father was a taxi driver,
Hairoil Sabarmati, Sonny
Ibrahim, Cyrus-the-Great,
and I. Others, too,
but there's no time now.
Because, with his eyes
narrowing in daylight,
crazy Zagallo is
calling us to order.
'Human geography,' Zagallo
announces, 'this is what,
Kapadia?'
'Please sir, don't know, sir.'
Hands fly into the air.
Five belong to church banned
idiots, the sixth inevitably
to Cyrus-the-Great.
But Zagallo is out
for blood today.
The godly are going to suffer.
'Filth from the jungle--'
he buffets Jimmy Kapadia,
then begins to twist
an ear casually--
'stay in class sometimes,
find out.' 'Ow ow ow yes, sir,
sorry, sir.'
Six hands are waving,
but Jimmy's ear
is in danger of cutting off.
Heroism gets the better of me.
'Sir, please stop, sir.
He has a heart condition,
sir,' which is true,
but the truth is dangerous.
Because now Zagallo is rounding
on me. 'So, a little arguer,
is it?'
And I am being led by my hair
to the front of the class.
Under the relieved eyes
of my fellow pupils--
thank god it's him, not us--
I writhe in agony
beneath imprisoned tufts.
'So answer the question.
You know what is
human geography?'
Pain fills my head,
obliterating all notions
of telepathic cheatery.
'Aiee, sir, no sir, ouch.'
And now it is possible to
observe a joke descending
on Zagallo, a joke
pulling his face
into the simulacrum of a smile.
It is possible to watch
his hand darting forward,
thumb and forefinger
extended, to note
how thumb and forefinger close
around the tip of my nose
and pull downwards.
Where the nose leads
the head must follow.
And finally, the
nose is hanging down
and my eyes are
obliged to stare damply
at Zagallo's sandalled feet
with their dirty toenails
while Zagallo unleashes his wit.
'See, boys, you see
what we have here?
Regard please the hideous face
of this primitive creature.
It reminds you of--'
and the eager responses.
'Sir, the devil,
sir.' 'Please sir,
one cousin of mine.' 'No
sir, a vegetable, sir,
I don't know which.'
Until Zagallo shouting
above the tumult, 'Silence!
Sons of baboons!
This object here--'
a tug on my nose--
'this is human geography.'
'How sir?' 'Where sir?'
What sir?'
Zagallo is laughing now.
'You don't see,' he guffaws,
'in the face of this ugly ape
you don't see the whole map
of India?'
'Yes sir.' 'No sir.'
'You show us sir.'
'See here, the Deccan
peninsula hanging down.'
Again, ouch, my nose.
'Sir, sir, if that's the map
of India, what are the stains,
sir?'
It is Glandy Keith
Colaco feeling bold.
Sniggers, titters
from my fellows,
and Zagallo taking the
question in his stride,
'These stains,' he
cries, 'are Pakistan!
This birthmark on his right
here is the East Wing,
this horrible stain
left cheek, the West!
Remember, stupid boys,
Pakistan is a stain on the face
of India.'
'Ho ho' the class loves,
'absolute master joke, sir.'
But now my nose has had enough.
Staging its own
unprompted revolt
against the grasping
thumb and forefinger,
it unleashes a
weapon of its own,
a large blob of shining goo
emerges from the left nostril
to plop into Mr. Zagallo's palm.
Fat Perce Fishwala yells,
'Look at that, sir!
The drip from his nose, sir!
Is that supposed to be Ceylon?'
[LAUGHTER]
His palm smeared with goo,
Zagallo loses his joking mood.
'Animal,' he curses me,
'you see what you do?'
Zagallo's hand releases
my nose, returns to hair.
Nasal refuse is wiped into
my neatly-parted locks.
And now, once again,
my hair is seized.
Once again the hand is
pulling, but upwards now.
And my head is jerked upright.
My feet are moving on to tiptoe.
And Zagallo, 'What are you?
Tell me what you are.'
'Sir, an animal, sir.'
The hand pulls harder, higher.
'Again.' Standing on my
toenails now, I yelp, 'Aiee sir,
an animal, an animal,
please sir, aiee!'
And still harder, still
higher. 'Once more!'
But suddenly it ends.
My feet are flat on
the ground again.
And the class has fallen
into a deathly hush.
'Sir, Sonny Ibrahim is saying,
'you pulled his hair out sir.'
And now the cacophony.
'Look sir, blood.'
'He's bleeding, sir.'
'Please sir shall I take him
to the nurse?'
Mr. Zagallo stood like
a statue with a lump
of my hair in his fist while I,
too shocked to feel any pain,
felt the patch on my head
where Mr. Zagallo had
created a monkish tonsure, a
circle where hair would never
grow again.
Two days later, Croaker
Crusoe announced
that, unfortunately, Mr.
Emil Zagallo was leaving
the staff for personal reasons.
But I knew what
the reasons were.
My uprooted hairs had
stuck to his hands
like bloodstains that
wouldn't wash out.
And nobody wants a teacher
with hair on his palms.
'The first sign of madness,'
as Glandy Keith was fond
of saying, 'and the second
sign is looking for them.'
Zagallo's legacy-- a
monk's tonsure, and worse
than that, a whole
set of new taunts
which my classmates
flung at me while we
waited for school buses
to take us home to get
dressed for social.
'Snotnose is a baldy' and
'Sniffer has a map face.'
When Cyrus arrived
in the bus queue,
I tried to turn the crowd
against him by trying to set up
a chant of 'Cyrus-the-Great,
born on a plate,
in 1948,' but nobody
took up the offer.
So we come to the events of
the Cathedral School Social
at which bullies became
instruments of destiny
and fingers were
transmuted into fountains
and Masha Miovic, the
legendary breast-stroker,
fell into a dead faint.
I arrived at the social with
the nurse's bandage still
on my head.
I was late because it hadn't
been easy to persuade my mother
to let me come.
So by the time I stepped
into the assembly hall,
beneath streamers and balloons
and the professionally
suspicious gazes of
bony female chaperons,
all the best girls were
already box-stepping and
Mexican-Hatting with
absurdly smug partners.
Naturally, the prefects
had the pick of the ladies.
I watched them with passionate
envy, Guzder and Joshi
and Stevenson and Rushdie--"
personal appearance--
"Talyarkhan and Tayabali
and Jussawalla and Wagle.
I tried butting in on them
during excuse-me's but when
they saw my bandage
and my cucumber
of a nose and the
stains on my face,
they just laughed and
turned their backs.
Hatred burgeoning in my bosom,
I ate potato chips and drank
Bubble-Up and Vimto and
told myself, 'Those jerks,
if they knew who I was, they'd
get out of my way pretty damn
quick.'
But still, the fear of revealing
my true telepathic nature
was stronger than my
somewhat abstract desire
for the whirling European girls.
'Hey, Saleem, isn't it?
Hey, man, what happened to you?'
I was dragged out of my
bitter solitary reverie
by a voice behind
my left shoulder,
a low, throaty voice, full
of promises, but also menace,
a girl's voice.
I turned with a sort of
jump and found myself
staring at a vision
with golden hair
and a prominent
and famous chest.
My god, she was 14 years old.
Why was she talking to me?
'My
Name is Masha Miovic,'
the vision said,
'I've met your sister.'
Of course, of course,
'I know,' I stuttered,
'I know your name.'
'And I know yours.'
She straightened my tie.
'So that's fair.'
Over her shoulders, I saw Glandy
Keith and Fat Perce watching us
in drooling paroxysms of envy.
I straightened my back and
pushed out my shoulders.
Masha Miovic asked
again about my bandage.
'It's nothing,' I said in
what I hoped was a deep voice,
'a sporting accident.'
And then, working feverishly
to hold my voice steady,
'Would you like to, to dance?'
'OK,' said Masha Miovic, 'but
don't try any smooching.'
Saleem takes the floor
with Masha Miovic swearing
not to smooch.
Saleem and Masha are
doing the Mexican Hat.
Masha and Saleem box-stepping
with the best of them.
I allow my face to adopt
a superior expression.
You see, you don't have to
be a prefect to get a girl.
The dance ended.
And still, on top of by
wave of elation, I said,
'Would you care for a stroll,
you know, in the quad?'
Masha Miovic smiling privately.
'Well, yeah, just for a
sec, but hands off, OK?'
Hands off, Saleem swears.
Saleem and Masha,
taking the air.
Man, this is fine.
This is the life.
Glandy Keith Colaco and
Fat Perce Fishwaller
step out of the shadows
of the quadrangle.
They are giggling.
He he.
Masha Miovic looks puzzled
as they block our path.
'Hoo hoo,' Fat Perce
says, 'Masha, hoo hoo,
some date you got there.'
And I, 'Shut up you.'
Whereupon Glandy Keith, 'You
want to know how he got his war
wound, Masha?'
And Fat Perce, 'Hee hee hee.'
Masha says, 'Don't be crude.
He got it in a
sporting accident.'
Fat Perce and Glandy Keith are
almost falling over with mirth.
And then Fishwala reveals all.
'Zagallo pulled his
hair out in class.
Hee hoo ha.'
And Keith, 'Snot-nose
is a baldy.'
And both together, 'the
Sniffer's got a map face.'
There is puzzlement on
Masha Miovic's face--
and something more, some budding
spirit of sexual mischief.
'Saleem, they are being
so rude about you.'
'Yes,' I say, 'ignore them.'
I try to edge her away.
But she goes on.
'You aren't going to let
them get away with it?'
There are beads of
excitement on her upper lip.
Her tongue is in the
corner of her mouth.
The eyes of Masha Miovic say,
what are you, a man or a mouse?
And under the spell of the
champion breast-stroker,
something else
floats into my head.
And now I am rushing
at Colaco and Fishwala.
While they are
distracted by giggles,
my knee drives into
Glandy's groin.
Before he's dropped,
a similar genuflection
has laid Fat Perce low.
I turn to my mistress.
She applauds softly.
'Hey man, pretty good.'
But now my moment has
passed and Fat Perce
is picking himself up.
And Glandy Keith is
moving towards me.
Abandoning all pretense
of manhood I turn and run.
[LAUGHTER]
And the two bullies
are after me.
And behind them comes
Masha Miovic calling,
'where are you
running, little hero?'
But there's no time for her now.
Mustn't let them--
mustn't let them get me.
Into the nearest classroom,
try and shut the door.
But Fat Perce's
foot is in the way.
And now the two of
them are inside too.
And I dash at the door.
I grab it with my right hand,
trying to force it open.
Get out if you can.
They are pushing the door shut.
But I'm pulling with
the strength of my fear.
I have it open a few inches.
My hand curls around it.
And now Fat Perce slams all
his weight against the door
and it shuts too fast for me
to get my hand out of the way
and it's shut.
A thud.
And outside, Masha Miovic
arrives and looks down
at the floor and
sees the top third
of my middle finger lying like a
lump of well-chewed bubble gum.
This was the point
at which she fainted.
No pain.
Everything very far away.
Fat Perce and Glandy Keith
fleeing to get help or to hide.
I look at my hand
out of curiosity.
My finger has become a fountain.
Red liquid spurts out to
the rhythm of my heartbeat.
Never knew a finger
held so much blood.
Pretty.
Now here's nurse.
'Don't worry nurse,
only a scratch.'
'Your parents are being phoned.
Mr. Crusoe is getting
his car keys.'
Nurse is putting a great wad
of cotton wool over the stump.
It's filling up
like red candyfloss.
And now Crusoe.
'Get in the car, Saleem.
Your mother is going
straight to the hospital.'
'Yes, sir.' 'And the bit?
Has anybody got the bit?'
'Yes, Headmaster, here it is.'
'Thank you, nurse.
Probably no use.
But you never know.
Hold this while
I drive, Saleem.'
And holding up my
severed fingertip
in my unmutilated left hand,
I am driven to the hospital
through the echoing
streets of night.
At the hospital,
white wall stretches.
Everyone talking at once.
Words pour around me like
fountains. 'O God preserve us,
my little piece of the moon,
what have they done to you?'
To which old Crusoe,
'Heh heh, Mrs. Sinai,
accidents will happen.
Boys will be boys.'
But my mother, enraged.
'What kind of
school, Mr. Carusoe?'
I am here with my son's finger
in pieces and you tell me.
Not good enough.
No, sir.' And now,
while Crusoe--
'Actually the name is
like Robinson, you know.'
The doctor is approaching
and the question
is being asked, whose answer
will change the world.
'Mrs. Sinai, your
blood group please?
The boy has lost blood,
transfusion may be necessary.'
And Amina, I am
A, my husband, O.
And now she is
crying, breaking down.
Still the doctor, 'In that case,
are you aware of your son's?'
But she, the doctor's daughter,
must admit that she cannot
answer the question,
Alpha or Omega?
'Well, in that case,
a very quick test,
but on the subject of rhesus?'
My mother, through her
tears, both my husband and I
are rhesus positive.
And the doctor, 'Well,
good, that at least.'
But when I am on the operating
table, 'Just sit there, son.
I'll give you a
local anesthetic.'
'No madam, he's in shock.
Total anesthesia would be
impossible.' 'All right, son,
just hold your finger up.
Keep it still.
Help him, nurse.
It will be over in a jiffy.'
While the surgeon is
sewing up the stump
and performing the
miracle of transplanting
the roots of the
nail, all of a sudden
there's a fluster
in the background
a million miles away.
And 'Have you got a
second, Mrs. Sinai?'
And I can't hear properly.
Words float across
the infinite distance.
'Mrs. Sinai, are you sure?
O and A?
A and O?
Rhesus positive, both of you?
Heterozygous or homozygous?'
'No, there must be some mistake.
How could--' 'I'm sorry,
it's absolutely clear.'
'Neither A nor--' 'Excuse
me, Madam, but he is your--
not adopted or--'
The hospital nurse
interposes herself
between me and the
miles-away chatter.
But it's no good because
now my mother is shrieking.
'But of course, you
must believe me, Doctor.
My god, of course,
he's our son.'
'Neither A nor O. And the rhesus
factor impossibly negative.
And zygosity offers no clues.
And present in the blood,
rare Kell antibodies.'
And my mother crying,
crying, crying, crying.
'I don't understand.
A doctor's daughter and
I don't understand.'
Have Alpha and
Omega unmasked me?
Is rhesus pointing its
unanswerable finger?
And will Mary Pereira
be obliged to confess?
I wake up in a cool, white,
Venetian-blinded room
with All-India
Radio for company.
Tony Brent is singing
'Red Sails in The Sunset.'
My father, Ahmed Sinai,
his face ravaged by whiskey
and now by something
worse stands
beside the Venetian blind.
Amina speaking in whispers.
Again, I hear snatches across
the million miles of distance.
'Please, I beg you.
No, what are you saying?
Of course it was.
Of course you are the--
how could you think I would--
who could it have been?
Oh God, don't just
stand and look.
I swear, I swear on
my mother's head.
Now she is--'
A new song from Tony
Brent, whose repertoire
today is uncanny.
'How Much is That
Doggie in the Window?'
hangs in the air,
floating on radio waves.
My father advances on
me, towers over me.
I've never seen him
look like this before.
'Abba.' And he, 'I
should have known.
Just look.
Where am I?
In that face, that nose,
I should have known.'
He turns on his heel
and leaves the room.
My mother follows him, too
distraught to whisper now.
'No, I won't let you believe
such things about me.
I'll kill myself.
I'll--' And the door
swings shut behind them.
There is a noise outside
like a clap or a slap.
Most of what
matters in your life
takes place in your absence.
Tony Brent begins crooning his
latest hit into my good ear
and assures me, melodiously,
that 'The Clouds Will Soon Roll
By'."
That will do for him.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
If you can stand another
one, I'll read another one.
I read those faster
than I usually do, so.
This is a short story.
So I thought at least I could
read one small complete piece
of work.
This is a more recent short
story, not about India.
This is a short story
with a very long title.
It's called "Christopher
Columbus and Queen Isabella
of Spain Consummate Their
Relationship, Santa Fe,
January 1492."
"Columbus, a foreigner, follows
Queen Isabella for an eternity
without entirely giving up hope.
In what characteristic
postures, proud yet supplicant,
the head held high, but the knee
bent, fawning, yet fearless,
possessed of a certain
saucy vulgarity,
he gets away with it by virtue
of his confidence man's charm.
However, as time passes,
the ingratiating aspects
of his stance are emphasized.
The sea dog raffishness wears
a little thin, as do his shoes.
His hope, it is of what?
Obvious answers first.
He hopes for preferment.
He wants to tie the queen's
favor to his helmet,
like a knight in a romance.
He owns no helmet.
He has hopes of cash and of
three tall ships, Niña, Pinta,
Santa Maria, of, in 1492,
sailing across the ocean blue.
But on his first
arrival at court,
when the Queen herself
asked him what he desired,
he bowed over her olive
hand, and with his lips
a millimeter away from the
great ring of her power,
he murmured a single
dangerous word, consummation.
'These unspeakable foreigners,
the nerve, consummation indeed,
and then following
in her footsteps
month after month as
if he stood a chance.
His coarse epistles,
his tuneless serenades
beneath her casement windows,
obliging her to have them
closed, shutting out
the cooling breeze.
She had better things to do, a
world to conquer and so forth.
Who did he think he was?'
Foreigners can be dogged--
and also on a count of
language difficulties,
fail to take a hint.
Then, again, let us not forget,
it is considered de rigueur
to keep a few foreigners around.
They lend the place a
certain cosmopolitan tone.
They are often poor
and consequently
willing to perform diverse
necessary, but dirty jobs.
They are, moreover, a
warning against complacency.
Their existence in
our midst reminding us
that there are quarters in
which, hard as it is to accept,
we ourselves would be
considered foreigners to.
'But to speak so to the Queen.'
Foreigners forget their
place, having left it behind.
Given time, they begin to think
of themselves as our equals.
It is an unavoidable hazard.
They introduce into
our austerities
their Italianate blandishments.
Nothing for it, turn a deaf
ear, look the other way.
They rarely mean real harm and
go too far only infrequently.
The Queen, be assured,
can look after itself.
Columbus, at Isabella's
court, is quickly
burdened with the
reputation of a crazy man.
His clothes are
excessively colorful.
And he drinks also to excess.
When Isabella wins
a military victory,
she celebrates it
with 11 days of Psalms
and the sonorous
severities of priests.
Columbus crashes about
outside the cathedral
waving a wine skin.
He is a one man debauch.
'See, him, that drunkard, with
his huge shaggy head filled
with nonsenses, a fool with
a glittering eye dreaming
of a golden paradise beyond
the Western edge of things.'
Consummation.
The queen plays with Columbus.
She promises him everything
he wants at luncheon
and cuts him dead later
the same afternoon,
looking through him
as if he were a veil.
On his Saint's day, she summons
him into her inmost boudoir,
dismisses her girls, permits
him to braid her hair,
and for a moment, to
fondle her breasts.
Then she summons her guards.
For 40 days she banishes him
to the stables and piggeries.
He sits forlorn on
horse-munched hay
while his thoughts run
on distant fabled gold.
He dreams of the
Queen's perfumes
but awakes gagging in a pigsty.
Toying with Columbus
pleases the Queen.
At pleasing the
Queen, he reminds
himself, may help him
to achieve his purposes.
Pigs rootle by his feet.
He grits his teeth.
Pleasing the Queen is good.
Does she torment him merely for
sport or because he is foreign
and she is unused to
his ways and meanings
or because her ring finger--
still hot with the memory
of his lips, his breath--
has been, how you say, touched.
Tentacles of warmth spread
backwards from her finger
towards her heart.
A turbulence has been aroused.
Or because she is torn between
the possibility of embracing
his scheme with a lover's
abandon and the more
conventional and
differently, maliciously,
pleasurable option of destroying
him by laughing finally
after much foreplay in his
foolish, supplicant face.
Columbus consoles himself
with possibilities.
Not all possibilities
are consoling, however.
She is an absolute monarch.
Her husband is an
absolute zero, a blank.
A blank couldn't be colder.
We will not speak
further of him.
She is a woman whose
ring is often kissed.
It means nothing to her.
She is no stranger
to blandishments.
She resists them effortlessly.
She is a tyrant who numbers
among her possessions
a private menagerie of 419
fools, some grotesquely
malformed others, as
beauteous as the dawn.
He, Columbus, is
merely her 420th idiot.
He is her clown,
her performing flea.
This too is a
plausible scenario.
Either she understands
him, his dream
of a world beyond
the world's end
so profoundly that
she's spooked by it,
she turns first
towards it, then away,
or she doesn't understand him
at all nor cares to understand.
Take your pick.
What's certain is that he
doesn't understand her.
Only the facts are plain.
She is Isabella,
all-conquering queen.
He is her invisible, though
raucous, multicolored,
winebibbing man.
Consummation.
The sexual appetites
of the male decline.
Those of the female continue
with the advancing years
to grow.
Isabella is Columbus' last hope.
He is running out of
possible patrons, sales talk,
flirtatiousness, hair, steam.
Time drags by.
Isabella gallops around,
winning battles, expelling Moors
from their strongholds,
her appetites
expanding by the week.
The more of the
land she swallows,
the hungrier she gets.
The more warriors she engulfs,
Columbus, aware of the
slow, shriveling inside him,
scolds himself.
He should see
things as they are.
He should come to his senses.
What chance does he have here?
Some days, she makes
him clean the latrines.
On other days, he is
on body washing duty.
And after a battle, the
bodies are not clean.
Soldiers go into war
wearing man-sized nappies
under their armor
because the fear of death
will open the bowels,
will do it every time.
Columbus was not cut out
for this sort of work.
It is getting him nowhere.
He tells himself to leave
Isabella once and for all.
But there are problems--
his advancing years,
the patron shortage.
Once he decamps, will have
to forget the Western voyage.
The body of
philosophical opinion
which avers that life is absurd
has never appealed to him.
He is a man of action,
revealing himself by deeds.
But without the
possibility of the voyage,
he will be obliged to accept
the meaninglessness of life.
This too would be a defeat.
Invisible in hot
tropical colors,
unrequited, he remains
dogging her footsteps,
hoping for the
ecstasy of her glance.
The search for
money and patronage,
Columbus says, is not so
different from the quest
for love.
'She is omnipotent.
Castles fall at her feet.
The Jews are being expelled.
The Moors prepare
their last surrender.
The Queen is at Granada,
riding at her Army's head.'
She overwhelms.
Nothing she has wanted
has ever been refused.
All her dreams are prophecies.
Acting upon information
received while sleeping,
she draws up her
invincible battle plans,
foils the conspiracies
of assassins,
learns of the infidelities
and corruptions
for which she blackmails
both her loyalists
to ensure their support and
her opponents to ensure theirs.
The dreams help her
forecast the weather,
negotiate treaties, and
invest shrewdly in trade.
'She eats like a horse
and never gains an ounce.
The earth adores her footfall.
Its shadows flee before
the brilliance of her eyes.
Her face is a lush peninsula
set in a sea of hair.
Her treasure chests
are inexhaustible.
Her ears a soft question marks,
suggesting some uncertainty.
Her legs--' her legs
are not so great.
She is full of discontents.
No conquest satisfies her.
No peak of ecstasy
is high enough.
See, there at the
gates of the Alhambra
is Boabdil the Unlucky,
the last sultan
of the last redoubt of all
the centuries of Arab Spain.
Behold, now, at
this very instant,
he surrenders the keys to
the citadel into her grasp.
There.
And as the weight of the
keys falls from his hand
into hers, she, she yawns.
Columbus gives up hope.
While Isabella is entering the
Alhambra in listless triumph,
he is saddling his mule.
While she dawdles in the
Courtyard of the Lions,
he departs in a frenzy
of whips, elbows, hooves,
all rapidly obscured
by a dust cloud.
Invisibility claims him.
He surrenders to its will.
Knowing he is abandoning
his destiny, he abandons it.
He rides away from Queen
Isabella in hopeless fury,
rides day and night.
And when his mule
dies under him,
he shoulders his
ridiculous gypsy
patchwork bags, their rowdy
colors muted now by dirt
and walks.
Around him stretches the lush
plain her armies have subdued.
Columbus sees none of it--
not the land's fertility
nor the sudden barrenness
of the vanquished
castles looking down
from their pinnacles.
The ghosts of
defeated civilizations
flow unnoticed down the rivers,
Guadal-this and Guadal-that,
their names retaining an
echo of the annihilated past.
Overhead, the arabesque
wheelings of the patient
buzzards.
Jews pass Columbus
in long columns.
But the tragedy of their
expulsion makes no mark on him.
Somebody tries to sell
him a Toledo sword.
He waves the man away.
Having lost his
own dream of ships,
Columbus leaves the Jews to the
ships of their exile waiting
in the harbor of Cádiz.
Exhaustion strips
him of his senses.
This Old World is too old.
And the New World
is an unfound land.
The loss of money and
patronage, Columbus says,
is as bitter as unrequited love.
He walks beyond fatigue,
beyond the limits of endurance
and the frontiers of self.
And somewhere along this
path, he loses his balance,
falls off the edge
of his sanity.
And out here, beyond
his mind's rim,
he sees, for the first and only
time in his life, a vision.
It is the dream of a dream.
He dreams of Isabella
languidly exploring
the Alhambra, the great jewel
she has seized from Boabdil
last of the Nasrids.
She is staring into a
large stone bowl held aloft
by stony lions.
The bowl is filled with blood.
And in it she sees,
Columbus dreams her seeing,
a vision of her own.
The bowl shows her
that everything,
all the known world is now hers.
Everyone in it is in her hands
to do with as she pleases.
And when she understands this,
Columbus dreams, the blood
at once congeals, becoming a
thick and verminous sludge.
Whereupon the Isabella of
Columbus' weary but also
vengeful imaginings is shaken
to her marrow by the realization
that she will never,
never, never be
satisfied by the
possession of the known,
only the unknown, perhaps even
the unknowable can satisfy her.
And at once she
remembers Columbus.
He envisions her
remembering him.
The invisible man who dreams of
entering the invisible world,
the unknown, perhaps
even unknowable world
beyond the edge of things,
beyond the stone bowl
of the everyday, beyond
thick blood of the sea.
Columbus, in this bitter dream,
makes Isabella see the truth
that lust makes accept
that her need for him is
as great as his need for her.
Yes, she knows it now.
She must, must, must give him
the money, the ships, anything.
And he must, must, must
carry her flag and her favor
beyond the end of the Earth
into exaltation and immortality,
linking them forever
with bonds far harder
to dissolve than those
of any mortal love,
the harsh and deifying
ties of history.
Consummation.
Isabella, in Columbus's
savage dream, tears her hair,
runs from the courtyard of the
Lions, screams for her heralds.
'Find him!'
She commands.
But Columbus, in his
dream, refuses to be found.
He wraps around himself
the dusty patchwork cloak
of his invisibility.
And the heralds gallop
hither and yon in vain.
Isabella screeches,
beseeches, implores.
'Bitch, bitch, how
do you like it now?'
Columbus sneers.
By absenting himself from
her court by this final
and suicidal invisibility,
he has denied her her
heart's desire. 'Serves
her right, bitch.'
She murdered his
hopes, didn't she?
Well then, in doing so, she
has laid herself low as well.
Poetic justice.
Fair is fair.
At the dream's end.
He permits the
messengers to find him.
Their hoof beats.
They're waving frantic arms.
They plead, cajole,
offer bribes.
But it's too late.
Only the sweet self lacerating
joy of murdering possibility
remains.
He answers the herald, a
shake of the head, 'No.'
He comes to his senses.
He is on his knees in the
fertility of the plains waiting
for death.
He hears the hoof
beats approaching
and raises his
eyes, half expecting
to see the exterminating
angel riding
towards him like a conqueror,
its black wings, the boredom
on its face.
Isabella's heralds surround him.
They offer him food,
drink, a horse.
''Good news,' they shout,
'the Queen has summoned you.
Your voyage, wonderful news,
she saw a vision and it scared
her.'
All her dreams are prophecies.
'She ran from the Courtyard
of the Lions shouting for you,
the heralds report.
She will send you beyond the
stone bowl of the known world,
beyond the thick
blood of the sea.
She is waiting for
you in Santa Fe.
You must come at once.'
He stands up like
a requited lover,
like a groom on his wedding day.
He opens his mouth.
And what almost spills out
is the bitter refusal, no.
'Yes,' he tells the heralds.
'Yes, I'll come.'
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]